تصاعدت حمله القمع ضد التظاهرات التي طالت
26 محافظه ايرانيه منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه شددا على ان انه في حال عدم
تعاون السلطات الايرانيه مع وفد لجنه تقصي
الحقائق فانها ستكشف عن جوانب اوسع من
جرائمها كانت الخارجيه الايرانيه اعلنت ان
النظام لن يتعاون مع الاليات الدوليه
لحقوق الانسان منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه قالت في احدث تقرير لها ان عدد
ضحايا الانتفاضه الشعبيه ارتفع الى 448
قتيلا على الاقل بينهم 60 طفلا وتسع
وعشرون امراه بيد الامن الايراني التقرير
سجل ايضا مقتل 16 مواطنا وذلك في مختلف
انحاء ايران في الاسبوع الماضي فقط طبعا
غالبيتهم من المناطق الكرديه هذه
الاحصائيه بحسب مراقبين تظهر الحد الادنى
من الارقام اذا انها لا تشمل سوى الحالات
التي سجل فيها باحثوا المنظمه وثائق
الشهادات الوفاء وايضا شهادات الطاقه
الطبيه طبعا من جهاتها منظمه العفو
الدوليه دعت الدول التي لها سفارات في
ايران الى ارسال مراقبين للمحاكمات
الجاريه للمتظاهرين المهددين بعقوبه
الاعدام المنظمه اشارت الى ان احدى هذه
المحاكمات ستكون محاكمه جماعيه نتحدث عن
احد عشر شخصا طبعا هذه المحاكمه الجماعيه
تبدا اليوم في محافظه باريس ما يعد
انتهاكا صارخا للقانون الدولي على حد او
وصف المنظمه العفو الدوليه عبرت عن قلاقها
البالغ من تقرير تشير لوجود اطفال بين
المهددين بعقوبه الاعدام في ايران طبعا
محاكمات يرافقها استمرار للقبض الامنيه
على الارض دعونا مشاهدينا نتابع صور
للقوات الامنيه الايرانيه كيف تنتشر في
مدينه سقف على دراجات ناريه
والان ننتقل الى شاه غربي
اطلاق نار ومظاهره ليليه عبر الشرفات
وايضا عبر النوافذ نتبعها معا
[موسيقى]